give you a fist bump
you can come you can come right to the
screen and do that where are you if you
want it where are you located right now
I'm in a box you're looking at me
I'm a germaphobe I'm right here
hilarious why is that hilarious come on
oh my God come on I'll do the whole
thing
yeah
boom
[Music]
I just met your son
and so uh yeah he told me to come say hi
so I wanted to say hi and give you your
flowers and say thank you for everything
you've done for the genre and comedy and
everything
well I want to say thank you to you for
being for being so entertaining and so
talented and coming on my podcast this
is a podcast oh this is a podcast
oh this is a whole misdirect I thought I
I the way this is being set up is that
my dad is in the other room he wants to
say hi and and
he pulled the heartstrings of Indian
respect he knows our culture there's no
way I cannot see someone's father and
pay my respects I just I didn't know I
was just being gaslit right now so this
is a whole this is all the farce this is
all built on a farce you had no idea I
had no idea I thought I would be going
to just uh uh a gray dull room in the
Doubletree Hotel Howie Mandel would be
sitting there alone by himself I'd give
you as my daughter I'll give you a fist
bump I'd meet your lovely daughter as
well and then oh no yeah this was
whoever comes in and sits down has
agreed to do a three and a half hour
podcast on the meaning of comedy and how
it's changing our culture sure oh got it
here we go okay you don't have to go to
the bathroom right now right where
where in the world are you in VR you're
just in Van Nuys California oh you're in
Van Nuys okay and it the Hub of a porn
got it and I didn't want with with your
daughter right yes and I didn't want it
are you do you want something you want
to promote something there's nothing to
promote I just wanted to come see you
and say hi and say thank you for Bobby's
World and thank you for when I first
started doing uh comedy I would see your
videos on YouTube and I always I asked
other people during that period of time
I go hey when we he was doing that thing
with the latex glove what what did that
mean
yeah but are you doing a Gala there are
you doing my own show here yes I'm doing
my own show fantastic couple in uh and
about I got in 20 minutes I have sound
check
yeah go go do your sound check but I
want to wish you the best and if you get
a chance to see Hassan live you gotta go
see him live it is great and you have uh
are you on what platforms are you on I'm
on Netflix I'm on Instagram you can find
me you can find me on the world wide web
just yeah just Google me and and you can
find it and you're no relation to Nikki
are you I I don't want to talk about my
sister right now I think this is about
me let's talk about my career and what
I'm doing
go ahead so I'm a comedian and yes I
have a family member that raps and is
very popular but I'd rather not talk
about it
do people ask you that a lot all the
time
but it's not the same last name not at
all not at all yeah not even yeah what
you're elucidating right now is how dumb
people are in America yes
it's not the same spelling uh we're not
from the same part of the world yeah
it's a yeah yes all right so see I told
you I didn't say that he said it sounds
No but you know what you know what this
is a lot of the banter that I have when
I go to a Starbucks yes people will ask
me this at Starbucks yeah it's kind of a
Starbucks question you go whoa huh
when I go to Starbucks they can't say my
name like they'll say they can't say ask
they don't say Howie I always got I'll
go they go name and I'll go Howie and
they go Harry and I go no Howie and they
go Harold and I go know how you should
do it and then you should do what I do
because we have both the same first and
I do hm they go really I go just call me
hm you should do hm
hmm it's it's it's accurate
and it's sincere you're just like hey
I'm not [__] with you just do hm and
if they want to know more then you can
tell them more and you say that when
they go can I have a name I'm not
[__] I'm not [__] with you yeah hm
yep wow I love it because I worked in
the Food Service I've gotten the yeah
Batman and you're like okay fine man
Batman you know I'm not doing that I'll
do just do hm
and I love the patches on your denim by
the way
thank you yeah by the way by the way I
mean one of the things I think is so
great is both you and Steve Harvey have
continued to dress better as time has
gone on so it's a bald thing me and
Steve yeah
yes and we do our hair this go to Steve
Harvey's Instagram he is in a in a
fashion Renaissance and I can't wait to
see the Howie Mandel fashion Renaissance
continue
um I'm in a Renaissance where if
somebody gives me something to wear for
free I put it on okay
I don't really Shop people send me
things got it but um what I didn't get
your daughter's name I'm so sorry
I'm Jacqueline hey Jacqueline I have a
nice time nice to meet you I have a
younger daughter she's four what were
your memories of your father when you
were four
oh these are good questions uh what did
you think Daddy did
at four no I didn't know he did comedy I
don't know I was touring with him at
that time he was touring around the US
and I would go on the tour bus with him
and we'd be in a different city every
night and I would beg to sleep on the
tour bus and knock it off at a hotel wow
those are my members that's pretty rad
what was it like weird what was it like
seeing your father as part of the Fox
comedy animated lineup
for your dad to be like a Saturday
morning cartoon on Bobby's World but you
know what the the character Bobby's uh
the neighbor was Jackie and that was
based on her and then I had her if you
go look you can YouTube Jackie in live
action on Bobby's World and I I let her
appear on the show so she did she
appeared on the show and when I was
touring with him you let me come out on
stage with you too yes she used to
introduce me as a cute little
four-year-old she used to say
thank you for coming oh thank you for
coming to my dad's show without you my
mom wouldn't be able to buy her
Mercedes-Benz thank you amazing it's not
so cute I know I know when you say it
now it's like hey why are you
speaking down to me
congratulations on all your family's
success okay yeah and and are you doing
a show just one night just one night
gotta get in and out that's where I'm at
in my career Hallie okay and you live
here in L.A I live in New York City
oh you live in New York City yes oh wow
but you got to come if you one day when
you have more time I would love you to
spend the uh time and you can do this
from New York City we have this box in
our podcast room and you you could be on
our podcast you could just hologram in
you ever you could be the Hologram I
could be there we could be two Holograms
talking to each other yeah no I will be
alone oh got it okay okay great yeah
let's do it would you be would you
hologram into the podcast sure see don't
you think that their Sparks should just
go all over and we could do stand up
like this instead of traveling I
disagree but I I respect uh I respect
your Neurosis I could see the audience
and I could talk to you and I could be
anywhere yeah I I I I I love Humanity
too much I want I want to see my fellow
man and woman and and I see my fellow
man I just don't want to smell myself
okay
this is a big difference I got you I got
you thank you all right what's that oh
wow what's that my award this is a
stand-up comedian of the year yeah 2020
congratulations when I said what do you
want to plug you said nothing you just
won at the Just for Laughs Comedy
Festival 40th anniversary you just won
stand-up comedian of the year how humble
are you congratulations thank you well
deserved appreciate that and what a
great human being and that's crazy that
you didn't even mention that no I'm I'm
speaking to a legend
must show respect to the Jedi so
wow yeah and I'm sorry that that you
feel that my son's a liar
no he's a sweet guy he's a very sweet
person I love his rugged beard
yeah
he let you rub it I just said he has it
rugged but he didn't let me rub it no no
I didn't I didn't want it well how do
you know it's rugged unless you rub it I
can just tell from the the the density
of it
um guys he's a rugged guy I gotta go to
my sound check thank you guys go I just
wanted to say hi Howie congratulations
thank you and and hi hi thank you nice
meeting you and I feel like we have met
yeah let's talk again take care good
luck bye thank you
foreign
[Music]